- Sur la plateforme Spotify,
parmi les chansons
et les albums, un balado
domine les palmarès.
"The Joe Rogan Experience"
attirerait près de 11 millions
d'auditeurs par épisode.
Mais celui du 31 décembre
a été très mal reçu.
L'animateur Joe Rogan
y discute avec le controversé
Dr Robert Malone, qui prétend,
entre autres, que les vaccins
à ARN messager contre
la COVID sont néfastes
pour les mineurs.
Plus de 200 professionnels
de la santé américains
ont dénoncé ce qu'ils qualifient
de désinformation.
Après avoir lancé un ultimatum
à Spotify, qu'icucucuse
de propager des théories
du complot, la légende du rock
Neil Young a retiré ses chansons
de la plateforme.
GENEVIE C C CÔTÉ, avocate
et chargée de cours, UQAM
- On peut imaginer que
dans le combat entre l'écoute
de Neil Young et l'écoute
J J Joe Rogan, Joe Rogan gagne.
- Donc, il faisait pas le poids,
autrement dit?
- On peut imaginer que les Dra
et The Weeknd, si eux décidaient
de retirer de la plateforme,
eux qui ont, disons, au moins
10 titres dans les top 100 de
chaque année les plus streamés
ototototify, on peut imaginer
que là, peut-être la réaction
de Spotify serait venue plus
rapidement.
- Le géant suédois, plutôt que
de se dissocier de Joe Rogan,
a annoncé des mesures
pour lutter contre la
désinformation, entre autres en
ajoutant des mises en garde aux
balados qui évoquent la COVID.
Mais d'autres artistes
quittent le service d'écoute
en continu, dont la Canadienne
Joni Mitchell et le chanteur
et poète québé
Gilles Vigneault.
ÈVE PARÉ, dg, vice-présidente
Affaires publiques, ADISQ
- Sur la question de Spotify,
c'est unorororororme
qui est incontournable,
on va se le dire,
pour la visibilité des artistes.
MARTIN LAVALLÉE, conseiller
juridique l,l,l,l,l, SOCAN
- Il faut que t'aies
une présence sur le numérique,
mais est-ce que les services et
les plateformes sont enlignés
avec le choix des artistes?
lllllà que j'ai un doute.
- Les artistes d'ici veulent
surtout une plus grande vitrine
sur ces plateformes.
Gilles Vigneault, par exemple,
compte 22 000 auditeurs
par mois, une fraction
de ce qu'obtient le balado
le plus populaire.
- Si Neil Youneueueueueut-être
pas le poids contre Joe Rogan,
on peut imaginer que
les artistes locaux du Québec
peut-être lenonononononon plus.
Mais d'enjoindre leurs fans à
ne pas utiliser le service, ça,
ça attaque le modèle d'affaires
de Spotify.
Joe Rogan, lui, s'excuse
et promet de diversifier
les opinions émises à
son émission. Il sera difficile
de lui faire compétition.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.